[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver pour votre rendez-vous sport
etc le sport français est agité ces
temps-ci par des problèmes de
gouvernance et de budget football rugby
au sécurité des manifestations sportives
nous allons revenir sur ces tempêtes qui
souffrent au sein des institutions voici
le sommaire
pour des raisons différentes les
présidents des fédérations de football
et de rugby ont été mis en retrait ces
dernières semaines quel avenir pour ses
poids lourds du sport français Amélie ou
des accastéral la ministre des Sports a
fait entendre sa voix mais pouvait-elle
vraiment faire plus faut-il réformer la
gouvernance des instances sportives nous
reviendrons également sur les
conséquences du refus de la Mairie de
Paris de vendre le Parc des Princes au
Paris Saint-Germain et enfin après
l'annonce d'un budget réévalué les JO de
Paris 2024 font face à des questions
cruciales de sécurité quelles
conséquences pour nos libertés
individuelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autour de la table aujourd'hui pour
débattre Jean-Jacques Lauzac vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de la Creuse Roxana
maraciné à nous ancienne ministre des
Sports et première championne du monde
françaises de natation c'était il y a 25
ans c'est un anniversaire qu'on a fait
il y a quelques jours Jean-Philippe
Leclerc vous êtes directeur adjoint de
la rédaction de l'équipe qui est notre
partenaire pour cette émission et Virgil
cahier délégué général de l'Union sport
et cycle bonjour à tous les quatre alors
je le disais les présidents des
fédérations de football et de rugby se
sont mis en retrait ces dernières
semaines alors ces deux situations très
différentes évidemment sur le fond des
affaires mais qui mène au même résultat
pour Noël le Great cette mise en retrait
est due un nouveau dérapage verbales une
accumulation de dérapage et pour Bernard
Laporte elle fait suite à sa
condamnation notamment pour corruption
passive ses présidents dans la tourmente
c'est le hors piste de sport etc
[Musique]
alors on va séparer footballe rugby on
va commencer par le football alors vous
avez sans doute entendu le tolé provoqué
par les déclarations de Noël le grec sur
Zinédine Zidane un dérapage verbal c'est
une qui fait partie d'une longue liste
de dérapage il a été mis en retrait lors
d'un comité exécutif de la Fédération
Française de Football est-ce que c'était
la meilleure transition possible
tout d'abord de manière plus générale je
dirais que c'est tourmente qui traverse
aujourd'hui le sport français pose le
problème de l'éthique et pour moi le
sport sans l'éthique ce n'est pas
véritablement le sport le sport porteur
des valeurs et notamment des valeurs
d'exemplarité des valeurs éducatives
auxquelles nous sommes tous très
attachés et par delà ces deux
fédérations je dirais qu'il y a une
crise de gouvernance parce que ce sont
des crises de gouvernance il y a une
crise qui est sans doute plus symbolique
que les autres c'est la crise qui
traverse cesnosf tout simplement parce
que la structure est symbolique le CNOSF
c'est la structure faîtière de
l'ensemble du sport français et
aujourd'hui même certains même cette
structure-là n'échappe pas à ses
difficultés de fonctionnement et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je pense que à
partir notamment de ces crises que
traverse deux fédérations très
importantes le foot et le rugby il
faudra en tirer les enseignements les
conséquences pour l'ensemble du
mouvement sportif
sur le football bon il y a à la fois des
analogies des différences entre ce qui
se passe dans le football et ce qui se
passe dans le dans le rugby et les
analogies c'est en particulier les
résultats sportifs les fédérations qui
obtiennent de bons résultats sportifs
notamment pour les équipes nationales
masculines et féminines on a un système
de formation qui nous est enviés partout
dans le monde et on a un problème de
président à la Fédération française de
football et de rugby alors tout à
l'heure vous avez employé cette
expression qui est commune maintenant
c'est à dire la notion de mise en
retrait qui n'existe pas d'ailleurs dans
les textes
juridique fédéral donc ça veut dire que
ces mises en retrait ne peuvent être que
des périodes transitoires des périodes
entre deux dont il va falloir sortir le
plus rapidement possible pour déboucher
sur des réalités plus solide et durable
on va y revenir et pour juste une
précision Virgile cailler c'est un
statut mise en retrait qui n'existe pas
dans les textes de la Fédération
Française de Football et exactement tout
à fait les deux situations sont très
différentes puisque d'un côté le
président de la Fédération française de
rugby a été condamné de l'autre côté on
en est encore à l'état d'un rapport qui
doit être mis prochainement à la
Fédération et à partir duquel
probablement les membres du COMEX
pourront pourront réagir mais cette
notion de mise en retrait n'existe pas
il y a la notion de vacance
d'empêchement donc si le président est
malade
du pouvoir parce que le président
vacances du pouvoir exactement la mise
en retraite d'ailleurs c'était très
intéressant puisque dans le communiqué
de presse qui est sorti par la
Fédération Française de foot c'est bien
Noël le Great avec l'accord du COMEX qui
a choisi de se mettre en retrait puisque
ça peut être qu'une démarche personnelle
ça peut pas être le Comex qui lui impose
de se mettre en retrait c'est donc
lui-même qui aurait décidé peut-être
sous la pression
elle vous paraît ubuesque cette
situation ou c'est vraiment la
continuité de
moi je trouve que c'est la continuité de
ce qu'on a initié d'abord avec Laura
Flessel qui a diligenté cette première
enquête qui a fait ministre des Sports
le raflutel quand je l'étais pas encore
ministre des Sports
que qui est aboutit la récemment pour la
mise à pied de Bernard Laporte et puis
ensuite tout ce que nous avons fait
lorsque moi j'étais au
dans ce mandat de ministre des Sports en
levant l'omerta déjà sur les violences
sexuelles dans le sport en travaillant
sur une loi avec le mouvement sportif
mais aussi avec tous les parlementaires
monsieur Lauzac était de la partie nous
a beaucoup soutenus aussi sur cette loi
et une loi proposée par les députés
soutenus fortement évidemment par le
gouvernement et les sénateurs également
parce que c'est essentiel à deux ans de
l'accueil par la France des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de montrer
une facette du sport à la hauteur de
l'investissement de nos athlètes on
attend de nos athlètes qu'ils soient
performants on sait énergie le travail
l'entraînement qu'ils mettent pour
l'être et moi c'est ce que j'ai toujours
dit au président soyons essayons d'être
au moins un dixième les instances
sportives les instances
officielles que mérite nos sportifs et
soyons exemplaires donc on a passé cette
loi pour déjà démarrer et proposer cette
réforme de la gouvernance du sport c'est
quelque chose d'inscrit dans la loi avec
trois mesures assez simples claires vous
allez détailler tout à l'heure et
maintenant j'allais dire c'est une mise
en application de tout ça et c'est une
continuité une suite à donner qui est
indispensable alors on parlait avant
l'émission de la rapidité à laquelle les
choses se passent dans les fédérations
temps de football que de que de rugby
Jean-Philippe Leclerc vous aviez
l'impression vous donnez le sentiment
que c'est quand même assez rapide ce qui
se passe oui c'est à dire que on peut
dire oui ça va pas assez vite on
voudrait que on bascule directement de
mise en retrait qu'on ajoute un E pour
que ce soit définitivement mis en
retraite mais si on la finale de la
Coupe du monde c'était il y a à peu près
un mois si au soir de la finale on nous
avait dit qu'un mois plus tard Noël le
gratte serait en retrait de la
Fédération française on aurait eu un peu
de mal à le croire après c'est quand
même lui qui s'y est mis tout seul parce
que je parlais des bons résultats de de
nos de nos sportifs je pense que et le
Great et Bernard Laporte quelque part ce
sont 6 centimes protégés par ces
résultats là et y compris nous les
médias on disait avant la coupe du monde
de foot voilà en gros si l'équipe de
France se fait éliminer au premier tour
c'est terminé pour le grec et et en fait
l'équipe de France est allé jusqu'en
finale de façon assez brillante et je
pense que lui s'est dit du coup je suis
je suis intouchable
entre guillemets si la France avait été
éliminée au premier tour à partir du
moment où c'est organisé parce que fort
des résultats à l'équipe de France au
Qatar si si il était resté je dirais à
sa place
déjà juste dans l'élégance
dans la posture du vieux sage etc et
tout mais là qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
il a pas pu s'empêcher en fait dire que
il est rentré dans une forme de de
combat complètement enfin stérile et
idiot avec avec la ministre enfin il a
fait des déclarations
après on dit alors ce qu'on a souvent
entendu dire ah oui il a fallu qu'il
critique Zidane alors que il y avait
quand même un lourd passif mais je pense
que ce qui s'est passé avec les
critiques entre Zidane c'est qu'en fait
il s'est aliéné sa propre famille et
puis il a que quelque part le coup de
grâce aussi avec
jusqu'à jusqu'au jusqu'à des
déclarations c'est son énième dérapage
donc là sur Zidane il y avait quand même
toujours une partie de la famille du
foot français qui disait oui il est un
peu vieux machin bon c'est vrai mais il
a tant fait pour le foot faut pas
oublier tout ça et tout mais là à partir
du moment où il a dérapé sur Zidane là
on s'est retrouvé avec tous les et
d'ailleurs le premier à réagir
pratiquement c'était Kylian Mbappé donc
la nouvelle génération plus tous les
anciens internationaux plus tout un tas
de gens dans le football qui se sont dit
pas fini et et je pense nous on a eu la
chance le privilège d'avoir l'interview
de Sonia Souid aussi donc il est agent
agent de foot et qui a témoigné qu'il
est la première à témoigner à visage qui
pouvait
le parquet de Paris a ouvert je pense
que elle a pris du courage aussi parce
que c'est jamais facile on sait bien de
de d'être la personne qui a découvert
dans son milieu dit voilà
il y a visiblement d'autres
témoignages dans le truc qui sont restés
jusqu'à jour là elle a eu le courage de
témoigner à visage découvert parce que
aussi à la senti qu'il y avait toute une
partie de sa famille le football qui
était en train de de basculer donc c'est
vraiment lui qui s'est mis tout seul
dans les ennuis c'est intéressant de
regarder la temporalité parce que en
vérité sur tous ces sujets là beaucoup
de gens savaient je pense qu'autour de
la table il y avait quand même beaucoup
de gens qui savaient même qui
entendaient ce bruit qui était au
courant de de d'un certain nombre de
choses on peut parler de France 2023 on
peut parler de la fédération de rugby de
la de foot tout ça sur un thème et
effectivement il faut casser cette
omerta Roxana il a contribué mais on est
sur des schémas différents et c'est pour
ça que ça c'est accéléré sur le foot
parce que pardonnez-moi le mot mais
enfin il a fait un master class de
conneries le grec il les enchaînés quand
même il a quand même été brillant
là-dessus c'est pour tous les les élèves
en communication de crise faut mettre ce
sujet là parce qu'il est vraiment
exemplaire et c'est ça qui a accéléré
les choses parce que sinon on serait
rentré dans une logique de procédure
parce que c'est indispensable parce
qu'on est dans un état de droit que
c'est la démocratie et qu'il faut que
chacun puisse s'exprimer et présumer
innocent donc effectivement ça prend du
temps aller au bout de la procédure et
là c'est effectivement comme le disjon
Philippe lui qui a accéléré le processus
et moi je au delà de de ces mots sur
Zidane je pense que c'est vraiment Sonia
sweat qui a été le déclencheur la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase et
cette enquête ouverte par le parquet de
Paris Jean-Michel Aulas qui est l'un des
soutiens de Noël le Great a dit que ça
commençait à devenir inquiétant après ce
que je intéressant dans ces deux cas
c'est que on va sûrement y revenir mais
à l'intérieur des fédérations il y a pas
de contre-pouvoir en fait c'est à dire
que on a des présidents tout puissants
et en fait le contrebouvoir il vient de
l'extérieur et là le contre-pouvoir il a
vraiment agi pour une fois pour tir
maintenant la main c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a eu un contre-pouvoir politique il y a
eu un contre-pouvoir médiatique et c'est
ce cette alliance pour une fois c'est
pas tous les jours entre le politique et
le médiatique qui fait aussi qu'à un
moment
il y a eu il y a eu une forme de de
ras-le-bol de dire non c'est pas
possible et c'est des affaires qui
peuvent pas être uniquement traité à
l'intérieur de la petite famille du
football ou de la petite famille du du
rugby on va s'intéresser au cas du rugby
puisque la mise en retrait est liée à
d'autres à d'autres raisons pour Bernard
Laporte qui était Président de la
Fédération Française de Rugby qui c'est
lui aussi mis en retrait après sa
condamnation à deux ans de prison avec
sursis pour corruption passive il a fait
appel de cette décision et il a déclaré
lui-même qu'il voyait pas pourquoi il
devrait s'en aller alors on va rejoindre
en duplex Abdellatif benazi l'ancien
capitaine du 15 de France vous êtes avec
nous au téléphone bonjour
de l'autre côté de la planète je
rappelle que vous êtes membre de valent
ensemble la liste d'oppositions menée
par Florian grill la liste d'oppositions
à Bernard Laporte clairement il se passe
quoi en ce moment-là
maintenant que l'État
les professionnels
[Musique]
la Coupe du monde donc il faut tout
faire pour
du rôle de l'importance du comité du
comité d'éthique Roxana nous c'est
quelque chose eux ça peut être un
contre-pouvoir
ça peut être un contre-pouvoir à
condition que le CNOSF prenne sa part
aussi du combat c'est vrai que l'État
nous notamment sur les violences
sexuelles et des beaucoup par la
précipitation qu'a provoqué le la prise
en considération par les médias de ce
sujet on a beaucoup réactivé ce réseau
des comités d'éthique et d'intégrité de
chaque fédération
bon qui était un peu consulté qui était
plus ou moins fort selon les fédérations
mais il faudrait que il y ait une
harmonisation je pense de toutes ces
voilà des sanctions proposées par
l'effet des en cas de des alertes ou des
signalements qui pourraient se faire par
ces comités d'éthique et d'intégrité des
avis qui sont rendus et que cette
harmonisation elle ne peut se faire que
par l'entité qui chapote le mouvement
sportif parce que l'État peut des choses
mais ne peut pas tout faire je rappelle
juste que les fédérations ce sont des
associations et même si elles ont
beaucoup de privilèges de la part de
l'État comme des voilà des des
privilèges de défiscalisation des
privilèges enfin des privilèges fiscaux
de le monopole aussi en tant que
fédération
ça reste quand même des associations
Jean-Jacques lozac et l'importance de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans le rugby
quand on est à 7 mois d'une Coupe du
Monde vous êtes inquiet il y a eu des
révélations encore cette semaine dans
l'équipe sur l'état du de l'organisation
de Paris 2023 oui tout à l'heure on
parlait du foot et donc d'une
défaillance individuelle aussi il y a
quelques analogies avec avec le rugby
effectivement le timing le calendrier
fait qu'on a toutes les raisons d'être
d'être très préoccupé moi vous savez je
crois que quand on arrive à un tel
niveau de tension un tel niveau de crise
dans une fédération je serai pas du tout
ce scandalisé que l'on repasse tout
simplement par le bulletin de vote tout
simplement dans les années
parce que n'oublions pas quand même que
le président d'une fédération il
s'appuie sur une double légitimité et
pas simplement sur la légitimité de
l'État c'est à dire la délégation pour
exercer une mission de service public
mais également sur la légitimité du vote
des représentants notamment des clubs
alors avec parfois des modes de scrutin
différents transport à l'autre donc il
faut vraiment s'appuyer sur cette double
légitimité et je crois que sur ce plan
là d'ailleurs la ministre des Sports
actuels a un comportement tout à fait
exemplaire en essayant de placer les
autres face à leur responsabilité je
crois qu'elle joue parfaitement sa
partition parce que elle a quand même en
face d'elle une espèce de Carcans qui
est le principe de l'autonomie de vous
sportif et effectivement il y a la loi
qui a été présentée par on va dire dans
quelques instants mais je pense que
effectivement il faut aller plus loin
que cette loi au regard de ce qui se
passe notamment dans ces deux
fédérations alors on pourrait se poser
la question est-ce que les fédérations
de sport en général en France fonctionne
de fonctions claniques est-ce que c'est
possible de faire quelque chose une
ministre est à l'offensive actuellement
c'est la prolongation de sport etc
on va écouter Amélie Oda Castéra qui
s'est exprimée très durement elle
parlait de Noël le Great je considère
que dans la fonction de Président il y a
un certain nombre de figures imposées
et je pense qu'il est profondément
défaillant sur l'une d'entre elles qui
est la représentation l'incarnation et
quand il s'agit en plus de la première
fédération de France
c'est très problématique on ne peut pas
continuer dans une situation
où il y a autant de sorties de route
où il y a autant de propos qui choquent
qui heurte
parfois qui sont une forme d'insultes à
ce que peuvent incarner un certain
nombre de légendes et tout ceci
est inacceptable
Roxana racine à nous si un milieu de la
Castéra peut s'exprimer comme ça
aujourd'hui c'est en c'est la continuité
de ce que ce qu'a commencé l'orage
Flessel ce que vous avez suivi ensuite
c'est ce qui lui donne la possibilité de
s'exprimer comme ça c'est vrai que le
ministère des Sports depuis des années
n'avait pas
revêtu pleinement sa mission qui est
celle de faire respecter la sécurité
dans la pratique sportive l'intégrité
l'éthique du sport et qu'on a mené à un
certain nombre d'actions mais la
première a commencé simplement par par
la durée
avec laquelle on a pu finalement mener
ses actions parce que c'est vrai qu'au
ministère des Sports quand on regarde
historiquement les ministres c'est vrai
d'ailleurs beaucoup de présidents ne se
gêne pas pour le dire vous êtes ma 10e
ministre vous êtes ma 11e ministre
remettez-vous en question déjà d'abord
parce que ça veut dire que vous êtes
trop trop longtemps mais aussi c'est une
vérité parce que c'est vrai que les
ministres des sports
passent vite reste un an un an et demi
et puis en fait on a rien le temps de
mettre en place moi j'ai eu la chance
pendant quasiment 4 ans de pouvoir et
les connaître et les côtoyer et
comprendre ce qui se passait et
comprendre les choses dans les réformer
dans la loi de faire ce que vous vouliez
mais mes prédécesseurs non c'est pour ça
que je dis que je vois d'un très bon
oeil aujourd'hui le fait que ce
ministère retrouve sa mission première
qui est celle de veiller à ce qui se
passe dans les fédérations déjà on a nos
conseillers techniques sportifs c'est
vrai qu'en début de mon mandat on a eu
un désaccord avec la commande que moi
j'avais eu de justement responsabiliser
tout de suite les fédérations alors
donnant ses ressources humaines
supplémentaires pour qu'elles puissent
se développer se déployer encore plus à
l'aune des Jeux Olympiques en France et
quand tout ce qui s'est passé avec les
violences de sport à émerger on s'est
vite rendu compte qu'il fallait au
contraire garder ses agents de l'État
renforcer leur lettre de mission pour
qu'ils puissent veiller au grain au sein
des fédérations et puis surtout que tous
ces comités d'éthique d'intégrité que la
gouvernance des fédérations et la
transparence la démocratie aussi
d'élections des présidents et des
gouvernants des des fédérations mais
aussi des ligues régionales parce que
tout part aussi de la base et bien
fallait qu'elle soit revue avant de leur
donner plus de moyens enfin tout en leur
donnant plus de moyens plus de
responsabilité plus de pouvoir mais en
même temps en veillant à ce que ils
puissent remplir correctement les
responsabilités qui sont les leurs et
leurs missions de représentation qui a
mis en avant Amélie odéa castéral à
l'instant Virgile cahier quand la
ministre des Sports s'exprime comme ça
c'est qu'elle a l'aval de l'Elysée une
espèce de
je pense
d'expliquer comment ça se passe entre le
château et le ministère des Sports à
Roxana qu'il avait qu'une
j'imagine que si elle va au front et qui
a mis un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière et qu'elle rappelle au
président de fédé qu'ils ont pas le
totem d'immunité avec la sortence peut
être irrévocable je suppose qu'elle
s'est baquée un peu et qu'elle a
effectivement le feu vert de l'Élysée je
l'imagine d'autant plus avec un Noël le
grec qui a été très longtemps proche du
pouvoir on le sait voilà néanmoins on
parlait à l'instant de gouvernance moi
je je me souviens du combat qui a mené
Roxana par rapport au président de fédé
pour obtenir l'histoire des mandats le
vote des clubs mais ça a été un combat
pied à pied c'est horrible donc ça veut
bien dire qu'ils ont une grande
difficulté à se remettre en question à
remettre en question cette gouvernance
qui est historique on parle d'une loi de
1901 car relativement peu évolué sur les
100 dernières années et le sport ne peut
pas être en dehors déconnecté de
l'évolution de la société donc il y a
des enjeux que le sport doit intégrer
absolument et voilà donc ce schéma de
gouvernance et puis les hommes moi je
suis persuadé qu'aujourd'hui on est un
point de bascule on a des nouveaux
dirigeants qui ont beaucoup plus les
pieds sur terre qui ont conscience de
tous ces enjeux de société et j'ai bon
espoir quand même qu'avec les outils de
gouvernance dont on dispose on puisse
aller vers quelque chose d'un peu plus
apaisé et responsable une évolution
fondamentale aussi je me permets de le
dire et qui a noté c'est que à deux ans
des jeux on a un ministère effectivement
qui s'occupe du sport mais aussi des
grands événements sportifs comme les
jeux mais aussi la Coupe du monde de
rugby en France et j'espère qu'après les
jeux ça continuera de cette manière là
parce que quand on connaît
l'organisation de l'État vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure est-ce que on a Laval du
Premier ministre ou du président Macron
pour y aller
effectivement quand un ministre des
Sports à tous les tous ces pouvoirs là
et qu'il a la capacité d'envoyer des
inspecteurs du travail dans un
inspecteur des finances sur les les
organismes qui organisent les grands
événements sportifs en France c'est sûr
que on a une capacité d'intervention
importante un rôle important et c'est ça
aussi faire changer la place du sport
qu'on veut en héritage des gens en
France c'est se dire aussi qu'on a un
ministère qui a un grand pouvoir et qui
est aujourd'hui écouté aussi par les
présidents de ces grandes fédérations je
vais me placer de l'autre côté
Jean-Jacques Lauzac c'est pas un peu
inquiétant l'État le gouvernement la
politique qui se mêle de sport ah non
pas du tout parce que justement je pense
que le sport est traversé de part en
part par la politique et depuis toujours
et depuis toujours donc je ne suis pas
du tout choqué par cela mais je reviens
sur ce que dit Madame la Ministre parce
que la loi du 2 mars 2022 qu'elle a
elle-même proposé a permis quand même de
sérieuses avancées en matière de
gouvernance et c'est même cette partie
là de la loi qui est véritablement avait
entraîné beaucoup de débats dans les
fédérations que ce soit dans le domaine
de la parité la limitation du cumul dans
le temps c'est quand même une véritable
révolution pas plus de trois mandats ou
bien encore l'élargissement du corps
électoral peut-être plus que un seul
ministre
[Rires]
honnêtement regarde ce qui se passe
actuellement je crois qu'il faut aller
plus loin je pense en particulier qu'il
faut davantage de prérogatives davantage
responsabilité pour les comités
d'éthique à l'intérieur des fédérations
parce que finalement le seul
contre-pouvoir officiellement qui existe
aujourd'hui dans les fédérations c'est
les comités d'éthique et puis je pense
qu'il faut aller vers également des
statuts type que l'on retrouve dans
toutes les fédérations parce qu'on dit
le sport il est diversifié il est
pluriel c'est évident mais je crois
qu'il faut une partie fixe en quelque
sorte pour toutes les fédérations afin
d'avancer en matière de démocratie
interne en matière de transparence et
puis et ça c'est nouveau et je crois que
c'est une bonne chose on commence à
parler de plus en plus des audits des
rapports de l'inspection générale très
souvent commandité par le ministère des
Sports et bien moi je pense que chaque
fois
qu'on se retrouvera dans ce genre de
situation il faut obligatoirement qu'il
y a ensuite un débat un débat public un
débat national à l'intérieur de la
fédération concernée et pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs d'orientation afin de
modifier la politique de la fédération
concernée parce que vous savez des
rapports des audits depuis 20 ans 25 ans
ils sont restés en grande partie notre
morte
[Musique]
oui mais sur le sur le foot il y a deux
choses qui s'additionnent à la fois
effectivement le rapport de l'Inspection
générale et puis l'enquête judiciaire
était lancée par le parquet donc c'est
l'addition en réalité de ces deux
phénomènes-là qui fait que la position
du président est devenue intenable c'est
totalement disqualifié Jean-Philippe
Leclerc justement c'est cette
accélération c'est cette ce mouvement
entre le l'Audi qui a été demandé cette
enquête à présent du parquet ça pousse
vers un changement de gouvernance mais
quel changement de gouvernance enfin
comment on peut voir dans les faits je
reviens je sais je suis sans doute trop
pressé j'ai envie que les choses
changent un peu trop vite oui parce que
si on prend par exemple l'exemple de la
si on prend l'exemple de la FIFA
la FIFA
avec Joseph Blatter on avait aussi un
président qui avait fait un voire deux
mandats trop on a eu aussi on a eu on a
eu aussi un scandale retentissant et on
a eu aussi une promesse de changement et
que voilà et l'élection d'un nouveau
Président si on prend masse de
changement vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir et tout aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec Jenny Infantino c'est
mieux que que Joseph Blatter donc là
effectivement là tout le monde enfin je
pense que aujourd'hui à part Noël le
grec peut-être ça peut-être sa femme
tout le monde est pour le fait que ça sa
mise en retrait de retraite
mais derrière il va falloir il va
falloir être vigilant sur la sur la
personnalité qui va arriver sur ce qui
va se passer parce que c'est pas parce
que vous vous débarrassez d'un président
qui a fait ce plus que son temps vous
allez vous retrouver forcément avec le
nouveau qui existe comme ça le monde de
Michel Platini qui a été évoqué dans
dans la presse non enfin il a été évoqué
je pense Michel Platini
pour l'instant c'est un peu compliqué
c'est à dire que il me semble
le fonctionnement des élections au sein
des fédérations c'est quand même très
cadré oui je pense qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui parachuté ça fonctionne il y a deux
conditions pour qu'il arrive déjà il
faudrait qu'il ait un signe du politique
qu'il a pas eu pour l'instant parce que
certains ont dit il a eu un appel de du
président Macron c'est pas vrai et
deuxièmement il faudrait qu'ils sentent
à l'intérieur de la FFF un mouvement ou
effectivement des gens assez influents
type par exemple le président Wallace
disent en gros nous on y arrive plus il
faut qu'on est quelqu'un qui viennent de
l'extérieur et et qui soit appelé un peu
comme le comme le sauveur voilà et
toutes ces conditions là sont pas encore
réunies et il faudrait que lui aussi ait
envie et aujourd'hui je pense que il y a
un matin il se réveille il se dit c'est
une belle occasion de revenir dans le
foot mon sport etc et puis un autre
matin le lendemain il se réveille en
disant j'ai sûrement pas replonger dans
ce tableau de crabes et je suis très
bien là où je suis donc je pense que
voilà c'est c'est loin juste pour
imaginer Michel Platini et Janine
Fantino la même réunion j'aimerais que
ça se fasse mais c'est la seule raison
parce que je pense que c'est deux hommes
ne s'aiment pas beaucoup des gens qui
font pas mon ménage en ce moment qui
sont qui s'entendent pas très bien ce
sont les représentants de la mairie de
Paris en la personne Dany dalgo et les
représentants du Paris Saint-Germain le
Parc des Princes n'est pas à vendre
c'est l'image de sport etc
[Musique]
alors j'avais bien imaginé une petite
annonce vend enceinte de 48 000 places
quartier résidentielles chic facile
d'accès en métro proche périphérique
rénové à hauteur de 75 millions d'euros
par l'ancien locataire mais finalement
un Hidalgo a été très clair le Parc des
Princes n'est pas à vendre
on en fait quoi du Parc des Princes
s'ils Paris Saint-Germain s'en va on
peut réfléchir à ça on peut passer un
peu de temps à
imaginer un peu virtuellement mais je ne
vois pas comment c'est possible que ces
deux-là ne s'entendent pas je vois pas
comment c'est possible d'ailleurs on
voit bien il pourrait se parler
d'être retissé l'un entre les deux
le Parc des Princes sans le Paris
Saint-Germain je vois pas ce qu'on peut
en faire accueillir des événements
accueillir des concerts des spectacles
il y a déjà le Stade de France il y a
déjà
Charléty voilà c'est non je vois pas
comment c'est possible
du stade Charléty c'est véridique il y
avait pas de club résident et on a eu
quelques brocantes au stade Charléty
c'est la vérité pour les téléspectateurs
qui n'habitent pas Paris c'est sans
doute le stade où il y a le plus de vent
le stade Charléty
et de la même manière le Paris
Saint-Germain n'a pas 36 options le
Stade de France ça pourrait être en être
une mais mais le stade paraît
surdimensionner
les supporters au Stade de France ça
sera compliqué et puis aller
reconstruire un stade exilo je vois pas
en fait pour construire un stade la
logique économique donc les deux sont
obligés de s'entendre
il y a eu un peu une une escalade des
prises de position et de l'agressivité
justement on va voir le tweet d'Emmanuel
Grégoire qui a essayé de d'apaiser lors
d'une conférence de presse le premier
adjoint la mère de Paris en charge
notamment de l'urbanisme il a essayé
d'expliquer avec Pierre rabathan qui
valait recommencer à discuter
Jean-Jacques loza qu'on peut pas
imaginer le Paris-Saint-Germain qui
était le Parc des Princes
de voir le PSG qui était le Parc des
Princes ne tient pas la route et je pose
la question pour aller où c'est le
président du Paris-Saint-Germain qui est
fâché contre contre Anne Hidalgo et son
boycott du Qatar c'est pour ça qui est
le Paris Saint-Germain en revanche
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
le dialogue se poursuit entre les
dirigeants du PSG et les élus de la
Mairie de Paris alors effectivement la
ville est propriétaire le PSG locataire
c'est un bail emphytéotique etc et c'est
un stade auquel
également des très attachés les élus
mais également l'ensemble de la
population parisienne mais aujourd'hui
il y a un problème il y a un problème
avec la nécessité effectivement de
procéder à des travaux de
d'agrandissement de modernisation de
respect de des mises aux normes
environnementales etc et je dis et je
dis que c'est ce que disait Virgile tout
à l'heure tout le monde a intérêt est-ce
que ces travaux de modernisation se
fassent aussi bien la ville de Paris
pour une question d'image et de retomber
financière etc et puis bien évidemment
les dirigeants du PSG qui pourront
passer de 48 000 à 60 000 places donc ça
veut dire davantage de billetterie
davantage d'hospitalité etc donc je suis
intimement convaincu effectivement que
tout le monde va se mettre autour de la
table et va trouver un contrôle
je pense notamment à Carlo livre
l'ancien maire de Poissy qui avait eu
une idée il a tout de suite dessiné un
stade pour imaginer le Parc des Princes
qui quittent Paris après on le rappelle
c'est au moins 10 ans de travaux je
parle j'ai lu qu'on parlait d'un budget
de 800 millions euros comme j'ai cru
comprendre que les finances du Paris
Saint-Germain il y a une notion
fondamentale c'est l'ego et l'orgueil
parce que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi il y a eu cet escalade là pour
une simple et bonne raison c'est à dire
que c'est à dire que avant la Coupe du
Monde il y a eu des déclarations des
deals parisiens de pierre rabanon en
particulier qui ont justifié le fait que
comme beaucoup d'autres municipalités
françaises il y aurait pas d'écran
géants pour regarder les matchs de Coupe
du Monde à Paris pour des raisons
climatiques mais il a dit avant les
raisons climatiques pour des raisons les
conditions dans lesquelles la Coupe du
Monde a été organisée au Qatar donc
c'était clairement une dénonciation de
tout ce qui a été dénoncé par plein
d'autres gens les morts sur les
chantiers le non-respect des droits LGBT
etc mais le fait que ça devienne de la
Mairie de Paris alors qu'ils sont
partenaires sont très souvent c'est ça
que les katariens ont pas supporter et
que Nasser en particulier n'a pas
supporté et c'est ce qu'il avait dit
dans nos colonnes en disant en gros il y
a un discours des édiles parisiens quand
on les rencontre au nom du
Paris-Saint-Germain on est formidable
vive le Qatar etc et un discours quand
on est à l'endroit où en revanche on est
on est le diable incarné donc
je pense que c'est escalade Nasser El
Khalifi c'est pas quelqu'un qui se lance
impunément comme ça c'est pas un sanguin
et qui se lance un punément comme ça
dans des déclarations et cetera donc là
je pense que vraiment il a ils ont été
vexé attends on a raison je pense pas en
train de les défendre absolument pas
mais en tout cas cet escalade verbale
elle a commencé elle a commencé là et
maintenant entre en tout cas entre les
grands chefs entre Anne Hidalgo et entre
Nassera et fille tout le monde dit oui
le dialogue va reprendre etc déjà
Jean-Claude Blanc plus être là et il
était quand même
de ce dialogue et je pense que avant que
le dialogue reprenne sur des bases
saines il va quand même se passer un peu
de temps parce que parce que ils sont
tous quand même enfin les les katariens
sont très sont vexés par tout ce qui
s'est passé vexé oui agacé parce que il
faut le savoir ça fait plusieurs années
que ça discute quand même donc c'est pas
un sujet qui sort du chapeau la
soudainement donc effectivement il
semblerait qu'il y a eu soit des
promesses en tout cas des engagements et
là c'est pas juste le Paris
Saint-Germain qui a décidé on veut
acheter le Parc des Princes il y a des
discussions il y a des discussions qui
sont ouvertes depuis effectivement un
moment et je rajouterai à cela aussi un
élément alors je sais pas à quel niveau
il peut jouer mais il est quand même
important c'est que le Parc des Princes
arrive à un moment où il a maximisé ses
revenus au travers du du Parc des
Princes le Paris Saint-Germain peut pas
aller beaucoup au-delà c'est seuls
options c'est effectivement d'augmenter
les sources de revenus liés à
l'hospitalité à ce qu'on appelle les
recettes jour de match et à une
ouverture de capital qui peut être aussi
une solution mais pour ouvrir le capital
et pouvoir valoriser le club encore
faut-il avoir des actifs la plupart des
clubs anglais sont propriétaires de leur
stade en Espagne ils sont propriétaires
de leurs Sade et là il y a effectivement
un déficit donc le fait de disposer
exactement donc là il y a aussi un petit
point faible dans la valorisation du du
club si d'aventure il souhaite ouvrir le
capital ce qu'ils ont plutôt d'ailleurs
annoncé donc ça ça milite aussi pour
envoyer des messages à d'éventuelles
investisseurs en disant regardez on fait
le max pour devenir propriétaire du club
à la question de Paris du Paris
Saint-Germain dans le parc on peut
imaginer Roxana nous un
Paris Saint-Germain propriétaire de son
stade et qui a grandi c'est l'objectif
c'est nécessaire est-ce que c'est une
possibilité quelque chose que vous
imaginez oui c'est pas le seul club qui
est dans cette situation j'avais discuté
avec le président de Nantes aussi qui
était dans la même tourmente avec la
ville à un moment donné décisif pour
effectivement agrandir ses fonds je
crois que c'est important aussi que que
qu'une ville qu'une municipalité puisse
garder aussi la main sur ses équipements
d'une manière ou d'une autre mais ça
demande beaucoup d'investissement donc
on est toujours voilà à se demander
est-ce que c'était le meilleur moment
pour se fâcher avec avec effectivement
Nasser ou pas ou est-ce qu'il fallait
rester droit dans ses bottes et assumer
ses valeurs effectivement
alors si on en croit Emmanuel Grégoire
en tout cas les discussions continuent
et si on parle de Paris Saint-Germain et
de budget on peut aussi s'interroger sur
cette opportunité le Paris Saint-Germain
est allé en pleine semaine en Arabie
Saoudite joint un match c'est on
l'appelle le match le plus cher de
l'histoire puisqu'il devrait rapporter
environ 10 ou 15 millions d'euros au
Paris Saint-Germain c'est Messi Ronaldo
bapé Neymar sur un même terrain c'est en
Arabie Saoudite c'est le Paris
Saint-Germain qui rencontre le club
d'alnasser le nouveau club de Cristiano
Ronaldo est-ce que l'Arabie Saoudite
copie le Qatar de toute façon il y a un
certain nombre de pays et de zone du
globe qui effectivement font du sport un
enjeu un enjeu diplomatique c'est ce
qu'on appelle le soft power la réussite
oui parce que je pense qu'on peut parler
de réussite de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar créer des jalousies dans les pays
autour donc moi je suis voilà
néanmoins on voit bien que sur ce
terrain du sport voilà il y a des enjeux
de suprématie et d'influence régional
donc le sport penchal est clairement la
Russie l'Asie le Moyen-Orient on voit
bien que le sport est un enjeu
diplomatique la prochaine Coupe du Monde
a lieu effectivement mais ça faisait
très longtemps que ça avait pas été sur
ce continent là alors on parle l'Arabie
Saoudite si je vous pose la question qui
a gagné le rallye Dakar parce que
normalement à cette période de l'année
au mois de janvier toutes les une de
l'équipe sont sur le Dakar et cette
année pas de une de l'équipe sur le
Dakar non c'est une interrogation je me
demande si le Dakar ne s'est pas perdu
dans les sables de l'Arabie Saoudite
parce que oui le Dakar je sais que c'est
pas une question de géographique
entre les entre les deux pays donc
pourquoi on l'a pas mis à la Une nous on
fait tous les matins on se dit voilà
quel est le meilleur sujet pour notre
une du lendemain
sur le Dakar qui a disparu c'était une
institution non non on peut pas dire que
que le Dakar est disparu ça a été un
bouddha car avec avec
Sébastien Loeb qui a gagné 5 ou 6 étapes
de suite alors à un moment il a crevé il
a perdu beaucoup de temps mais il est
revenu c'était un beau Dakar après
pourquoi on l'a pas mis à la lune parce
que ce jour-là on a estimé qu'il y avait
un événement plus important mais on
néglige pas du tout le Dakar et pour
revenir sur l'Arabie saoudite et le
Qatar cette tournée à 10 millions elle
est très symbolique parce qu'ils sont
entraînés au Qatar et ensuite ils sont
allés en Arabie Saoudite et c'est beau
pays c'est deux pays qui ont profité du
sport aussi pour se réconcilier puisque
on a vu pendant la coupe du monde au
Qatar c'était un événement incroyable le
prince est venu le prince saoudien est
venu à assister à un match on a vu venir
du Qatar avec le avec le drapeau donc
tout ça c'est s'il y a un enjeu d'argent
pour le PSG mais je dirais que pour les
katariens il y a un enjeu diplomatique
qui est encore encore plus fort c'est ce
qui est fascinant dans le sport on va
rester dans des questions de budget mais
pas tout à fait du même ordre on va
parler de 4,4 milliards d'euros c'est le
budget réévalué des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 et c'est le
chiffre de sport etc
[Musique]
alors le 12 décembre dernier le cojob le
commutateur organisateur des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques a annoncé
que son budget a augmenté de 10,1%
passant de 3,9 milliards d'euros à 4,4
la gestion de bon père de famille est-ce
que c'est ça qui est pas respecté
Virgile Caillet moi je crois qu'il faut
relativiser une révision budgétaire
c'est très sain on est à deux ans des
jeux c'est bien de le faire maintenant
c'est bien de s'apercevoir
qu'effectivement il y a eu de légers
dérapages voilà je sais plus qui est
employer le terme de vent de face devant
contraire évidemment cette inflation
cette incertitude peut-être des lignes
budgétaires à réévaluer notamment au
niveau de la sécurité moi ça me semble
pas illogique on est à un dépassement de
de 10% c'est ça et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il faut employé ce terme de
dépassement et non pas de dérapage ou de
délires budgétaires on est encore dans
des budgets qui sont très raisonnables
si on les compare aux précédent
disposition moi je suis pas trop inquiet
au contraire je trouve qu'on fait le
travail dans le bon sens dans le bon
ordre et c'est maintenant qu'il faut
réviser et pas s'apercevoir qu'on a
dépassé après l'événement Jean-Jacques
lazac vous vouliez ajouter oui en effet
il y a quelques jours le premier
président de la Cour des comptes
c'est-à-dire Pierre Moscovici est venu
présenter devant le Parlement à la fois
le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale la
situation budgétaire de ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et je crois
qu'il a parfaitement joué son rôle de
lanceur d'alerte et j'ai été étonné en
particulier par cette mise en garde
tournée autour des questions de sécurité
aussi bien en termes de système
d'organisation de la sécurité en lien
notamment avec la cérémonie d'ouverture
et puis d'autre part l'impact financier
qui concerne on va justement l'écouter
pierre moscovicii je vous redonne la
parole la Cour souligne que le plan
global de sécurité doit impérativement
être arrêté pour entrer dans une phase
d'organisation opérationnelle des moyens
si par site sous l'autorité des préfets
par ailleurs le risque capacitaire que
j'évoquais il y a une seconde reste à
relever notamment on regarde de la scène
d'ouverture qui se déroulera sur la
scène improbable renfort pour partir de
force de sécurité intérieure pour
exécuter des missions relevant
l'organisateur compte tenu du déficit
que j'évoquais probable de force de
sécurité privée doit être anticipée
j'ajoute que son financement doit être
assuré par le kojob il n'y a pas de
raison qu'il repose sur le contribuable
n'oublions pas que les forces font face
par ailleurs à un défi d'équipe
d'émission il y aura les missions liées
au jeu mais il y aura aussi la
permanence des mesures de sécurité sur
l'ensemble du territoire il s'agit pas
de se dégarnir
Jean-Jacques Lauzac oui non mais il n'y
a pas à ce stade de dérive ou de
dérapage il y a simplement des
incertitudes parce qu'on connaît
toujours pas le coût réel des Jeux
Olympiques au moment où on parle mais il
faut bien se dire que derrière tout ça
il y a la question de l'héritage
olympique parce que l'héritage olympique
c'est pas simplement gagner des
médailles gagner des médailles pardon
organiser des épreuves mais aussi
maîtriser le budget et la question du
degré d'acceptabilité sociale de ces
Jeux Olympiques et les dimensions
budgétaire n'est pas absente de cela non
plus je veux dire par là que l'opinion
publique les Français vont comparer tout
simplement le budget prévisionnel au
moment de la de l'acte de candidature et
puis c'était saisi 9 milliards d'euros
bon après les choses ont été précisées
on est arrivés à 8,1 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui on est à 8,8 bon ça va se
terminer à 9,5 milliards d'euros rendez
loin du dérapage tout un ensemble
d'autres jeux olympiques si on prend les
JO on est parti de quatre on est arrivé
à 12 mais Pierre Moscovici parle de la
sécurité notamment de la sécurité de la
de la cérémonie d'ouverture qui doit
payer pour la sécurité des Jeux
Olympiques il a été très clair le
premier président de la Cour des comptes
ça doit relever du kojob et non pas des
contribuables et non pas des
contribuables est-ce que c'est possible
globalement on peut dire que sur les 9,5
milliards d'euros que c'est José
olympiques et paralympiques vont coûter
une fine on aura environ 2 milliards
d'euros de financement public mais alors
tout compris je parlais de sécurité une
sécurité privée le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin a parlé de
remettre en question certains festivals
parce que ça va être difficile de mettre
des forces de l'ordre tant sur les Jeux
Olympiques que sur les festivals donc je
comprends bien que c'est le kojob qui
doit payer mais c'est pas le cojob qui
va payer la police nationale et la
gendarmerie qui sécurisera comme dans
les grands événements sportifs quel
qu'il soit que il y a une facture qui
est présentée au grand aux événements en
question qu'ils soient culturels un peu
plus de de faveur
faites aux organisateurs mais dans le
monde du sport les organisateurs
d'événements certes ont une ristourne
mais ils payent quand même la sécurité
mais pour répondre à votre question
c'est un mix des deux c'est une sécurité
publique et privée qu'on doit développer
fortement parce que de toute façon
c'était un secteur la sécurité qu'on
devait
développer depuis des années et ça fera
aussi partie de l'héritage de ces jeux
que d'avoir enclenché voilà des
formations supplémentaires pour des
jeunes qui seront eux pas prêts là pour
24 mais en tout cas avoir un peu
libéralisé un peu plus ce secteur de la
sécurité en France
un ministre a raison là actuellement en
l'état actuel des choses nous n'avons
pas assez de personnel de sécurité
privée
[Musique]
voilà exactement même si on présente
l'ensemble des sociétés de sécurité
privée elle est sublime sur le papier
cette cérémonie d'ouverture sur la scène
que ce soit sur la scène pour les pour
les Jeux Olympiques que ce soit vers la
Concorde pour les Jeux paralympiques
enfin moi aussi j'aimerais qu'on mette
ce plateau sur tout en haut de la tour
Eiffel mais il y a aussi une question de
moyens
depuis le début il est contre et encore
aujourd'hui il est contre
la scène et c'est le président Macron
qui lui a pas laissé le choix d'accord
une sorte de consensus pour une fois
politique entre la mairie de Paris le
président de la République et aussi le
kojob qui ont voulu cette cérémonie mais
Darmanin depuis le début il est il est
debout sur les freins à dire c'est pas
raisonnable on peut pas le faire donc
donc là il essaie d'abaisser par exemple
le nombre de de personnes qui ont accès
à cette à cette cérémonie et je dirais
que c'est pas complètement public il
faudra acheter des places enfin c'est
c'est pas juste s'approcher à trois
niveaux en fait j'irai aussi qu'il y a
le pour moi l'état d'esprit général a
changé depuis la la finale de la Ligue
des Champions c'est à dire que ça a été
un tel fiasco que avant on avait un peu
tendance y compris nous les médias se
considéraient nous les Français un peu
comme les champions du monde
on va jouer une grande partie des jeux
sur cette cérémonie et on sait combien
la cérémonie est importante en termes de
symboliques Londres a pu lancer ses jeux
de façon formidable parce qu'ils ont eu
une cérémonie absolument formidable
sinon on a une cérémonie moyenne ou
voire encore pire
derrière il va falloir ramener justement
cette question de la sécurité elle est
centrale puisque cette semaine un projet
de loi est intitulé organisation des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques 2024
est arrivé au Sénat il est beaucoup
question de sécurité
en effet c'est un texte éminemment
sécuritaire sur les 19 articles il y a 8
articles concernant la sécurité je
souligne votre utilisation du mot
sécuritaire
c'est un texte de mise en oeuvre tout
simplement des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques c'est un texte de
dérogation des dérogation dérogation aux
droits communs parce que c'est un
événement tellement exceptionnel qu'il
faut déroger au code du sport
les JO et 11 qui sont pas sur les jeux
on peut se demander si ce texte ne
concernera pas toutes les organisations
toutes les manifestations sportives
après oui dans ce que vous dites est
absolument essentiel parce que le titre
est quand même un peu trompeur il paraît
en effet ce sont c'est un texte Jeux
olympiques mais c'est également un texte
post-olympique si je peux dire c'est à
dire qu'il y a un certain nombre de
mesures un certain nombre de
dispositions de reconnaissance faciale
on parle d'intelligence artificielle
utiliserait il y a des dispositions qui
vont être pérennes
à d'autres manifestations l'expression
qui est employée d'ailleurs c'est
manifestations récréatives sportives et
culturelles ça veut dire qu'il y a des
articles qui figurent dans ce texte de
loi qui est ensuite vont s'appliquer sur
le plan sportif lors de nos championnats
nationaux par exemple ou lors de la
Coupe du monde de rugby dans quelques
semaines mais également pour les
festivals culturels pour les concerts
etc donc c'est un texte important parce
qu'il dépasse dépasse les Jeux
Olympiques justement je pense aux
activistes qui dénoncent qui ont dénoncé
ces derniers temps sur les leurres de
manifestations sportives la non-action
des gouvernements dans la lutte contre
le changement climatique une invasion de
terrain si j'en croise ce projet de loi
ne sera plus une infraction mais un
délit passable de six mois de prison et
7500 euros d'amende ah oui on durcit
un durcissement des peines qui est
envisagée moi ce qui me gêne je dois
dire dans
ce qui me gêne je dirais dans ce texte
là c'est que cette relation entre
l'organisateur et le public et
essentiellement appréhender à travers la
pression à travers la répression
notamment la lourdeur des peines or
c'était l'occasion puisque tout à
l'heure je viens de dire que c'est un
texte également post-olympique c'était
aussi l'occasion de poser la
problématique de la relation entre par
exemple club professionnel et
association de supporters et là on
aurait dépassé très largement le simple
volet de la sanction on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui je prends l'exemple des
clubs de foot mais pas simplement plus
de déplacement puisque les préfets
prennent des arrêtés à tour de bras non
mais je crois que en termes notamment
d'animation par exemple la proximité des
enseignes sportives en termes
d'organisation des des déplacements en
termes de recours à des référents qui
représenteraient ces associations de
supporters au sein de l'administration
de la gestion d'un club sur ces sujets
là je peux vous dire que il y a matière
à progression en France aujourd'hui il y
a effectivement dans quelques clubs
professionnels qui se sont emparés de
cette problématique à bras le corps mais
ils sont aujourd'hui largement
minoritaires après heureusement que la
Loire entre pas dans ce niveau de
détails et qu'on laisse quand même un
petit peu quelque chose à faire au club
professionnel qui ont tellement d'argent
quand même qui qui pourraient quand même
se demander comment faire pour arriver à
mettre ne serait-ce qu'une bonne
ambiance dans les stades qu'on évite des
banderoles homophobes et qu'on évite
d'écrire raciste dans leur tribune quoi
ça c'est quand même un peu la
responsabilité des clubs quand même on
va leur quand même leur laisser un petit
truc et puis après oui évidemment la loi
elle se elle s'oriente et elle met en
avant des sanctions parce que c'est
aussi ce qui est demandé par le par la
Ligue par les clubs professionnels pour
qu'on puisse aussi leur donner des
outils pour pouvoir intervenir c'est ce
qui ce qui a été sur la table pendant le
débat sur les violences dans les stades
c'est vrai que je me rappelle d'un de
d'uneanimité autour de la table on a dit
mais ça viendrait pas à l'aider de qui
est aucune sanction et que tout le monde
se permet de monter sur une scène lors
d'un concert lors d'un événement
culturel que le public envahissent la
scène c'est pareil pour un pour un stade
de foot à un moment donné il faut
peut-être marquer noir sur blanc que
c'est un voilà c'est le sanctuaire des
joueurs et c'est là qu'il joue c'est
l'axe déroule le spectacle et que le
public n'a rien à y faire pendant le jeu
en tout cas pendant le temps de jeu je
suis assez d'accord avec avec cette
analyse de la loi moi je pense que la
loi va encore puisque c'est un projet de
loi on est en première lecture au Sénat
si je dis pas de bêtises en procédure
actuelle
et il y aura je crois que c'est 24 mars
sur les sécurités sur la sécurité les
libertés individuelles
il y a effectivement il faut être
vigilant et je suppose que les
parlementaires feront leur travail
là-dessus pour poser les limites mais de
toute façon c'est un texte qui est
indispensable puisqu'on doit se mettre
en conformité avec la Charte olympique
donc il y a de toute façon des
dispositions dans ce texte qui sont
quasiment obligatoires je crois qu'il y
a déjà plus de 21 amendements c'est ça
je dis pas de bêtises donc c'est un
texte qui va vivre encore
mais mais effectivement euh
Jean-Philippe Leclerc moi je pense qu'il
faut être vigilant parce que le le sport
c'est souvent de de laboratoire
dans la dans des nouvelles techniques de
de de
répression de de maintien de l'ordre
on a vu les cas le cas par exemple en
Russie vous parliez de la reconnaissance
faciale dans le cadre de la Coupe du
monde de football on s'est servi de les
autorités russes en sont servis pendant
la coupe du monde de foot et au pire
ensuite ils sont sont servis pour
imprimer leurs propres opposants donc on
sait pas ce qui peut se passer y compris
dans ce pays on sait pas ce qui va se
passer après la prochaine élection
présidentielle qui va être élu et et on
a dans cette émission pas mal salué
enfin le l'action du politique sur le
sportif mais entre l'action et
l'ingérence des fois la frontière est
assez est assez mince et je pense qu'il
faut il faut être très vigilant par
rapport à ces à ces textes là et ce et
ce que le sport arrête d'être ce
laboratoire parce que c'est du sportif
parce que c'est des supporters en gros
on peut faire un peu ce qu'on veut et
puis ensuite c'est le simple citoyen
c'est l'opposant qui se retrouve très
attentif effectivement à ce à ce projet
de loi merci merci à tous les quatre on
ne peut pas évidemment terminer cette
émission sans rendre hommage au roi Pelé
qui nous a quitté le mois dernier un
immense merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
un immense merci à toutes les équipes
éditoriales et techniques qui m'aident à
préparer cette émission et nous on se
retrouve le mois prochain sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]